[Música]
digital é para o bem ou para o mal
nós temos algum tempo já de experiência
com digital aqui no brasil eu tenho
acompanhado isso ao longo dos últimos 20
anos nessa experiência a transformação e
essa revolução digital e aí fica a
pergunta é mesmo tendo acompanhado isso
todo esse tempo eu ouço algumas
colocações assim bem interessantes que
provavelmente vocês também já ouviram
por exemplo a internet acabou com a
socialização entre as pessoas né
ninguém nem janta junto mais todo mundo
fica tirando fotos do prato para
compartilhar com quem tá fora do jantar
nem assim redes sociais é uma perda de
tempo as crianças só querem saber de
jogos virtuais estão completamente sem
foco
ou então coisas do tipo eu nem sei usar
isso aí direito então alguns de vocês já
devem ter ouvido esse tipo de coisa
ou então asfic news que a gente vem
acompanhando ao longo do tempo por
exemplo essa mais recente que foi da
baleia azul que trouxe uma um medo muito
grande para muita gente a gente também
rondado o tempo inteiro pelo fantasma da
pedofilia ligada ao mundo digital e
outro risco que todo mundo comenta né
acho que cada um de vocês deve ter
alguma história parecida à que perigos
são esses encontros marcados pela
internet porque houve um caso de uma
fulana que foi assassinada relacionado a
isso encontros pelos aplicativos tem
ainda o medo dos ataques hackers né que
recentemente a gente tem ouvido uma
série de invasões hackers e as pessoas
também ficou com muito medo disso
ou então medo que a gente tem de se
tornar obsoleto de agente é deixar de
acompanhar toda essa mudança
vencendo então o medo da obsolecência
principalmente com relação ao mercado de
trabalho né
e as empresas que dão super expostas e
também amedrontados com relação à
postura dos novos consumidores porque os
consumidores como a gente sabe somos nós
ea gente está cada vez mais crítico mas
agressivo nas redes sociais há hoje o
que a gente chama de uma tecnofobia
praticamente uma rejeição aí é o que vem
do mundo digital só que a questão que
fica é será que é isso mesmo será que a
gente realmente perdeu o controle sobre
toda essa massa de informações
eu prefiro ver as coisas de uma outra
forma eu acho que com aquela história
que tem a metade do copo meio cheio
metade meio vazio eu sempre prefiro ver
o lado meio cheio né prefiro ver as
coisas como oportunidades mas é óbvio
que nós temos ainda muitos desafios pela
frente o desafio da atualização
constante todos nós porque assim como a
internet ela traz esse medo da
obsolecência ela também traz ao mesmo
tempo várias possibilidades de
atualização né
todos nós temos essa sensação de ficar
meio desorientado meio perdido em algum
momento ea gente também tem o desafio de
como utilizar a tecnologia a nosso favor
para que a gente consiga construir uma
vida ainda melhor
então como eu disse agora a pouco eu
trabalho muito com essa questão das
oportunidades eu prefiro ver é esse
universo novo como repleto de
oportunidades cada um de vocês deve ter
utilizado pelo menos um aplicativo
desses antes de vir pra cá
seja para descobrir o melhor caminho
mais rápido qual é o localização ou um
hotel para a hospedagem então todos nós
temos hoje acesso a muito mais
funcionalidades do que a gente tinha
antes
alguns de vocês devem utilizar esses
aplicativos de relacionamento também
tirando aquele medo que a gente comentou
agora pouco né
muita gente tem conhecido pessoas
bacanas utilizando o meio digital eu
mesma conheci meu ex-marido há mais de
12 anos
utilizando uma ferramenta dessas que nem
chamava aplicativo na época e me casei
tive meu filho né
as empresas estão é cada vez mais
conseguindo contratar pessoas com melhor
qualificação por conta do mundo digital
porque você tem acesso a muito mais
informação sobre os candidatos e os
candidatos também podem analisar melhor
aquela empresa para verificar se ela faz
sentido se eles gostariam de trabalhar
lá ou não né
a tecnologia também está facilitando
muita coisa com relação por exemplo até
o tratamento de algumas fobias né
tratamento de medos então a gente vê a
realidade virtual atrelada a vacinação
de crianças a fobia de voar a fobia de
outras questões né
o edital também pode trazer pra gente
uma vida mais prática por exemplo a
gente não precisa ficar perdendo muito
tempo hoje numa fila do supermercado
então numa fila cinema é pra comprar um
ingresso por que aliás tempo é hoje o
nosso maior ativo é a gente tem que
realmente tentar dedicar mais tempo para
fazer aquilo que a gente gosta
cada um de nós vai alocar o tempo aquilo
que é mais importante pra gente é como
brincar por exemplo com o nosso filho
outra oportunidade que eu vejo bastante
é o em o crescimento do empreendedorismo
ligado ao universo digital hoje a gente
tem inúmeras empresas que têm surgido
pra solucionar problemas resolver
lacunas relacionados ao mundo digital
muitas empresas vendendo todo tipo de
produtos e serviços utilizando mundo
digital a possibilidade de formação
contínua assim como o digital nos
empurra para uma necessidade dia se
atualizar e também traz ferramentas para
que a gente proposta o tempo todo está
se atualizando e isso pra mim foi
superimportante porque literalmente não
tivesse essa conexão não conseguiria ter
reinventado porque fiquei conectada com
o mundo o mercado de trabalho
mesmo amamentando meu filho que nasceu
há 16 anos e pouco e reinvenção porquê
porque alguns anos eu fui demitida e aí
aquilo que pareciam
uma tragédia um problema muito grande na
verdade acabou sendo tudo que eu
precisava para empreender e empreender
justamente utilizando caminhos
relacionados ao universo digital e além
disso a gente tem outros exemplos nem
ligados por exemplo a área política que
que o digital pode nos passar com
relação à área política ele tem foi
influenciado diretamente o resultado de
algumas eleições seja para o bem ou para
o mal né quando obama ganhou em 2008 ele
utilizou muito do universo digital para
se comunicar e a gente acompanhou
recentemente também eles a lei eleição
do trampo que também teve muita
influência do digital
mas não só isso né tem convocadas
pessoas para irem para a rua para se
manifestarem seja por uma linha ou pra
outra mais tem convocado as pessoas para
uma participação
o digital não me traz muita
transparência se a gente for ver com as
relações sejam entre empresas e
consumidores seja entre políticos e
cidadãos porque expõe tudo né entre
pretendentes e até entre empresas e
funcionários
então na verdade e fica tudo muito mais
é evidente muito mais transparente
então além disso digital também trouxe
muito mais velocidade à todas as
transformações que a gente tem observado
muitas dessas tecnologias que hoje estão
nas nossas mãos
aconteceram nos últimos dez anos se não
fosse o digital spy levar mais de 100
anos para acontecer
então realmente tá tudo migrando para a
palma da nossa mão e aí o que é
importante é importante que a gente
adapta o nosso mais de 7 realmente a
questão é o nosso a nossa forma de
pensar
não importa se a gente é nativo digital
o agente imigrante digital porque
ninguém mais vai querer parar de
utilizar a internet para se comunicar
com os filhos por exemplo que estão
morando fora do país ou então a vovó que
levantou a mão ali que a minha mãe para
brincar com neto ou com um alguns
sobrinhos então você hoje ninguém quer
parar de estar conectado ou então pra
gente realmente como eu falei dedicar
mais tempo aquilo que faz bem pra gente
eu vejo ficar fazendo supermercado eu
faço supermercado
sentada na sala de casa para poder
curtir mais o meu filho
então não tem volta esse caminho não tem
mais volta
então o que nos resta né não ser nos
reinventarmos porque o digital é para o
bem ou para o mal
tudo isso é verdade tanto o lado bom
quanto o lado ruim
a questão maior da ligada às nossas
escolhas o que a gente resolve fazer o
uso do digital a gente pode continuar
disseminando fake news como aquele caso
da baleia azul
hoje a gente pode utilizar para fazer
bem para as pessoas através de um site
colaborativo ou mesmo é de crowdfunding
né pra apoiar algumas necessidades
humanas
a gente pode utilizar também para não
parar mais de estudar porque não adianta
mais a gente fazer um curso e parar
daqui pra frente o que a gente precisa
fazer realmente não pára mais dia
aprender desaprender e reaprender de
novo
se a gente perder essa possibilidade a
gente realmente corre riscos
e falando em riscos será que é uma
ameaça
o digital ele realmente só vai ser uma
ameaça para as pessoas que desistirem
outras pessoas que não quiserem se
adaptar que não quiserem se atualizar
aí ele corre a gente foi realmente um
risco porque o digital não é culpado de
nada ele na verdade é uma ferramenta
somos nós que usamos e nós que fazemos
escolhas sobre o que fazer com esse
caminho
então a gente tem que ter muito claro
quais são os nossos objetivos a utilizar
essas diversas e poderosas ferramentas
porque a gente sabe bem que a diferença
entre veneno e o remédio tá na dosagem
né
então fica aqui a pergunta pra vocês
digital é para o bem ou para o mal
a escolha está nas nossas mãos
[Aplausos]